two one
good afternoon everyone i'd like to
welcome you to the live q a session for
theme number one
the science of infectious disease as we
get started this afternoon
i'm going to do a quick roll call just
to confirm that our speakers
are live and available so
dr ewing are you well online and can you
confirm you can hear me
yes hello good afternoon
thank you dr dexy chen are you online
and can you confirm that you can hear me
yeah i can't hear graphene
thank you dr sujata are you online and
can you confirm that you can hear me
yeah now we're here thank you oh loud
and clear thank you
and dr shaymilak are you online and can
you confirm that you can hear me
uh yes i can hear you oh fantastic
i want to thank all of our presenters
today they
presented some fascinating work i'd like
to get started with the q
a so um the first question is for dr
ewing excellent work um identifying the
adaptive
er stress and reduced metabolic
metabolic function of the tca
cycle of the baseline conditions that
contribute to an individual's
progression
to developing symptoms post-infection
with the yellow fever vaccine
you discuss several possibilities that
could potentially be driving the subset
such as bmi genetics age microbiome etc
as you look to what we've seen with
covid clinical presentations thus far
can you comment on where you'd like to
see the field focus their efforts
thank you that's a that's a really good
question that i i
i'd love to kind of understand how
whether this er stress and metabolism
has have a rules to play in the
pathogenesis of coca-19
obviously the challenge there is going
to be recruiting the cases
before they're infected and trying to
understand what is that baseline
state both in terms of the er stress as
well as metabolism
that that would be a major challenge and
maybe in in household clusters
or um you know in
nursing homes or dorms that may be
possible but i think beyond that it may
be very difficult but
the key to that would be to try and
recruit the cases before the onset of
symptoms
ideally even before infection and that's
hard and that's why in some ways the
vaccine gives us that
opportunity to standardize when
infection actually occurs
another way of do coming at that is just
to use you know drugs like metformin
which obviously
modulates er stress as a way of asking
whether
you know that would have any impact on
changing the cause
but those are you know there's quite a
lot of work to be done to address all
those questions
thank you
thank you um so the next question that's
come in
is for for doctor ducky chuck
can you talk about one of some of the
next projects that you have coming up
um looking at elevating cb8 positive t
cells in the immune system of severe
covingting patients so what's next on
the horizon for you
so dr chen are you still with us
double double positive t-cell
can you repeat your question yeah
how about i'll rephrase it slightly so
maybe you can talk about
what are the what's next up for you in
terms of the projects you have coming up
when you look at the immune system of
severe coving 19 patients
so what would you like to see is your
the next progression of your projects
well i spent a while on
our next project mainly focuses on the
molecular mechanism
so we run the more than 200 genes
in the canon wireless rankings
patient samples the pbmc and
i think we will find the more cell
signal possibly
how effective the double-pole g-cell
of cd-8 t-cell or
tgf beta produces cells how deregulation
to affect the correct kill or severe the
another linking virus
disease process thank you
thank you um dr alan this next one is
for you
um you've done some really nice work
with the different morphology
of the dengue virus you suggest
treatments or vaccines that incorporate
multiple morphologies as you come and
they are all infectious
can you comment on the relative
infectivity of each morphology
um and then a follow-up question or
actually i'll let you answer that one
first and then there's a follow-up
question
okay um so for the dengue mature
and dengue mature they their infectivity
is similar
so for the immature virus because they
infect a different
cell completely so i cannot compare
directly
but they they can infect by
different pathways like binding to
disease positive cells
and also um yeah their infectivity can
be assisted by antibody because um
antibody can help them to bind to fc
receptor on macrophages which are the
target cells
and uh for the for the club shaped
particles uh
you know because there's only twenty
percent you know like a plug essay
that shows you in terms of locks right
and you won't see much in terms of locks
so um but your ability to attach
to the virus is about the same and
as the mature virus and
and also the
they they contain rna so we think that
is infectious too
okay thank you um so this is a question
actually um for for the group and so
maybe we could take turns
or maybe have one or two answers but um
in terms of can some of you speak to
your collaboration opportunities with
other researchers
how has this the pandemic impacted your
ability to collaborate
has it increased um has this you know
talked about different partnerships that
have perhaps developed
and given you greater opportunities
i guess i can be happy to start
um no it actually
it opened up a lot of opportunities i
mean i don't normally work on
coronaviruses but i guess now it's kind
of like all hands on that
situation and so um you know we do what
we can
and the collaboration that we have with
accuracy therapeutics is uh
actually born out of a
initiative a tie-up that the economic
development board of singapore uh
you know initiated between us and after
his therapeutics and that's how it came
about and
you know prior to this epidemic this
pandemic i
i had not thought about working on the
money vaccine so it's one of those
you know great opportunity it came along
it was too good to pass
so i think there's many more such
instances i'm sure
thank you uh fascinating actually has
anyone else had a um
a a opportunistic um
you know way for the the pandemic that
in terms of creating a new way to
collaborate
or work across disciplines or public or
private space i'd like to hear
maybe some one of our other speakers
comment on this
well find my personal experience has
been that uh
this pandemic has opened doors of
different uh groups of researchers b is
chemist be it a vaccinologist
basic researchers who all have come
together to join hands to understand the
disease
in a more holistic manner and that is
very important in tackling
uh any disease uh which uh which i have
been seeing so
even though it has presented
more opportunities in terms of different
kind of collaborations which we would
not have been thinking about
at other times what is important is to
maximize this opportunity in disease
management
as well as an understanding i think
artificial intelligence has come up in
such a big way in the last
seven months that it hasn't done in the
couple of years except for those experts
who are actually working on that
so this is this is the time which i feel
that we need to
uh maximize the
the partnerships that have come from
different uh group of
experts uh in fact
infectious diseases in general and of
course covet in particular
thank you actually this building on that
that comment um we've had a question
in as a proafter
approach what has been
the use of ai within predicting future
viral strains that can cause this
pandemic and
do you what do you see for that um
either in your work today or in the
future
yes it was telling that um
like even i mean i told in the
presentation there's a lot of noise
that's present right now and that is
something we really look into it we need
to
de-learn the information that we've got
see about the good information
and then use it for um
predicting or understanding what could
be the new
uh re-emerging or new viral strings
that has been uh unheard of in at least
the human population
uh to study what what kind of evolution
that has been happening in these viruses
it could be sebastic species it could be
viruses that have been
largely presented only to the
animal sciences but yes
we can definitely make use of artificial
intelligence to understand what could be
or predict the kind of
novel viruses that could be that could
be coming in the
future you know of infectious diseases
thank you so um i have
another oh yeah absolutely please go
ahead
it's gonna say thanks i i totally agree
with that view that you know i mean
i think we now have um great tools like
artificial intelligence you know that
help us with our work throw through the
public databases and literature
um to help us make a more educated
guesses on on what to expect next
but i also think that you know in in
these
public publicly available information
there's also a lot of noise that you
know we
could be very difficult to see through
sometimes without experiments
i think you kind of need both at this
point in time i don't think that
you know artificial intelligence
and all that is only as good as the data
that is fed into it and we still need
better data
thank you so i
actually thank you that's uh it's a
great sort of pivot in terms of
speaking about the data i'd like to post
those questions to all of our speakers
if it touches on on your research and in
all of your research in some respects
but
can you comment on the recent reports of
covaid reinfection
i i can start i guess um yes i mean i i
don't think a reinfection
is at all surprising um
obviously the question is what is the
risk of severe disease relative to the
first infection and
whether that then you know constitutes a
thing to worry about for the future
um and i think for that you know the
case report is coming out
it's not clear enough it's that um know
i i personally have not seen any data
come from
and i know that there's more than one is
now being um
suggested across the world so it'd be
good to see the data and understand
what's the difference between the first
and
second infection but at least in so far
as the first case report
on this subject it does look like the
adaptive immunity
that was generated from the first
infection seemed to have protected
the patient from
from what i can gather was that the
subject had sub-detectable
antibody levels and maybe that was why
uh the person got re-infected but with
the t-cells then
perhaps that's why it became
asymptomatic
but it'll be important to see this um
the evidence for all these other
reinfections that are beginning
across the world and understand whether
they're first of all
truly any infection or a misdiagnosis
thank you
so go ahead
yep go ahead thank you please no go go
ahead
there have been there have been cases of
reinfection or reports of the infection
in india as well
so a couple of things we need to look uh
really closely when we
when we assign a case as the infection
uh one is whether after the first time
whether they have developed antibodies
or if they are still negative for
antibodies and the second thing is the
second
important aspect is how what was the
real-time pcr data which looked like was
it qualitative was
the viral load known and if if it was
qualitative what was the ct value if
you're gonna have
already high cp value which speaks about
very less viruses
whether um that or whether it was
actually a reinfection
or the virus present hidden in as
in maybe it was in the reservoir and
then it
comes up at another late later stage
so these are the few aspects that we
need to look into
on an individual case basis before we
actually assign a specific case as
reinfection so we still
need to do a lot of work before we
actually
uh use this term and
uh then look into the science behind it
because right now the important aspect
is
how are the clinical clinicians going to
deal with the whole system
the biology comes later and these are if
you're going to have a metrics for the
clinicians to
um define a reinfection versus a
retribution or it has been so these are
important aspects we need to define
first before we go and claim that
yes there has been whatever we see as
the infection is
truly a case of the infection thank you
thank you so i'm looking for i'm just
making sure i go through the questions
and so we have a
couple more coming through here and then
i
when i go through here i think that um
so this is a question actually that just
popped up in terms of um
dr locke do you agree that better
understanding of the human microbiome
will help researchers to come up with
alternative approaches
to handle viral infection
[Music]
is that for doctor we i think
not luck
um semi oh is that me
i don't study human bio microbiome
it must be for someone else it's a
mistake
just i'm just reading the question here
my apologies here do we have someone
else that would like to take that one
is that a question on human microbiome
is that is that what it is
yeah i think so okay okay uh
yeah i i can't happy to take that um
it's a great question and
no one really knows right now i think
the human microbiome
as a
hot area of research obviously um we
know that the microbiome
influences the immune response in
various ways right from the you know
from the immune response all the way
through to
the idea that maybe even influences um
uh um
blanking out in terms but anyway the
innate immune response
does undergo some epigenetic changes
and it influences and microbiome may
actually influence that process
and that then affects how it responds to
other acute infections
but i don't think it's well understood
right now and it's hard to
kind of interrogate it clinically uh
difficult to change people's microbiome
uh steadily across time so that we can
understand its impact on health and
and with regard to how we respond to an
acute infection
thank you
thank you okay so i'm not going back to
dr
locke in terms of looking at the
underlying protein structure and you
spoke a lot about
the e1 protein conformations between the
smooth and the spiky viruses
in regards and changes to temperature
can you comment on other
potential physiological factors that you
think might be contributing
um so right now uh
yeah right now um the temperature is the
most
obvious but i think the ph also affects
um so we kind of know at least for
dengue virus two
at ph eight the virus surface is tighter
and then
as you go lower ph seven point something
the surface become a little bit looser
so the ph also kind of matter
yeah um but every strain is
different because some strains are
really very tight i mean they're so
tight that when you run a rest
when you run lvs pistol um the e
proteins
you know remain associated with it with
each other we see like monomers diamonds
climbers spectrometers
and the higher molecular weight are
protein so
yes thank you okay um we have another
question here for dr oy
and then this is back to um with cova 19
typically taking
five to six days passing post-infection
before we're able to capture
them clinically so the inflammatory
response is already at play
and it's really quite you know genius
using the live
yellow vex yellow fever vaccine to
understand the implications
of the baseline contribution what
differences between yellow fever and
cova 19
infections do you expect or predict
great question again thank you um um i i
guess
you know from what we have been able to
see from yellow fever vaccine i think
all we can say
is that um you know the likelihood that
the those people who have underlying
adaptive er
stress and lowered uh krebs
psychoactivity
um you know upon infection because an
infection then
requires both protein production which
would excessive er stress
and energy therefore it keeps the cell
over into a maladaptive er stress
response and that then leads to symptoms
and i think that's that's all that we
can say about it because beyond that
what then leads to severe disease i
think it is
viral burden dependent right uh in the
case of dengue yellow fever it will be
viremia because you can measure that in
the blood
but covet covet 19 maybe not because the
viral burden the sas could be 2 burden
is in the airway
and likelihood the lower area which is
not not easy to sample
and so i think the the the subsequent
inflammation process that then
differentiates those who get mild
disease
versus those who get severe disease
because of the
the inflammation i don't think is er
stress
driven at that point i think it's virus
driven
so i think the er stresses can only go
so fast explain
why some people do not get symptoms even
though they're infected with the same
virus
so so that you know the progression to
severe disease i think it's a
and a whole different layer of biology
added on to this
fundamental uh
differentiate and differentiate
differentiation between the
symptomatic and asymptomatic infection
thank you
so we have another question coming in
here and
in terms of if the if a cova-19 vaccine
is made available
um is there a which target group is
considered important to receive the
vaccine
and is there you know not just one
target group but
other multiple groups that we'd like to
target and i you know
like to open this up for discussion
across the group
i'll be happy to start so um i mean
that's a great question and i suspect
that that's something that
would be different from country to
country um
obviously you would one definitely want
to target the vulnerable group
uh right from the outset uh those you
know the old the elderly
the uh those the co-morbidities the the
people who are more susceptible to
severe
uh disease with uh saskomi to infection
however that also has to be balanced
with what we will eventually
uh be determined through phase two and
possibly three clinical trials um
because the vaccines in general don't
work very well
in the elderly and so if that's the case
then vaccinating the elderly may not be
the most efficient way of applying the
vaccine
we may want instead want to vaccinate
those who care for the elderly so family
members
staff from those in homes and all that
and the healthcare
workers who you know uh look after these
um
elderly patients uh so it really
i think and then of course the you know
in some countries where
where there is higher rates of
hospital-based infections then it would
definitely make sense to
vaccinate the healthcare workers and
then after that
the population but i think it depends on
country to country
for instance in singapore we we've had
hardly any
i think there were a handful of uh uh
healthcare workers who were infected um
but by and large the problem was
actually mainly in the community
uh especially in the migrant worker
dormitory so
you've got to have to vaccinate where
the problem actually is
thank you
before it's a nice question when any of
our other speakers like to comment as
well
just in terms of the question or
further add their
opinion to that answer
well you know i think uh young is right
you know we should um
uh vaccinate you know the elders
uh so because they are the ones that
could be
uh more endangered you know by this
kovid infection and
likelihood of severity desire and also
people in the first line like you know
those who work in hospital
and grocery stores and those who
interact with lots of people
okay so we have another question coming
in here in terms of um
pandemics normally follow a common
pattern and we hear that many of the
pandemics of the past have had wave one
two and sometimes three with respect to
cova 19
is there any information on which wave
is currently in progress in specific
countries
i guess um i don't know about the other
speakers from my news
but what i know comes from the news as
well so if anyone's reading the news
you'll get the
updates and i mean to me it looks like
france is
appearing to have a you know another uh
the cases are looking to have an
exponential growth again
and i suspect that this will apply to
those countries and relax
their control measures a little bit too
much perhaps
um and so you know i think
we should expect a second we should
expect a third wave until a vaccine
becomes available i don't think this
virus is going to go away
at all it's become too entrenched in the
human population too many people already
have it and carry it
and it can be easily transmitted right
but it's not as easy as
not as highly transmissible as in
measles or anything but nonetheless
uh you know the estimated reproduct
basic reproductive rate of an r
naught is about you know somewhere
between two and four or
round three um still large enough to be
of concern um so i think the the trick
the tricky part is how do we maintain
this kind of social distancing and
control measures mask wearing and all
that when first of all is not um
ingrained in the way most of us are
brought up
and and it's it's very counter to human
psychology and some
to some extent so it's it's hard to bear
but
uh you know until a vaccine becomes
available this is the only way we can
we can stop uh or reduce virus
transmission
so actually i have a question um so you
know
i heard some report also from the news
that some italian doctors and spanish
doctors say that the virus has gotten
weaker um because there are less severe
cases in their hospital i mean is that
true or or is just that
those with severe cases already have
gotten the disease and so
you know the leftovers are the strong
ones and therefore you don't have
much severity i mean the severity case
are lower
my own uh impression um
was that the initial wave in italy
um affected the elderly and that's why
there were so many deaths and i think
now
it's affecting many younger adult
population and so the disease
outcome seems to be a lot better i don't
think that
the virus has changed sufficiently to be
able to make such a difference in the
outcome
obviously there are mutations and you
know our colleague
gavin smith found one deletion in the
genome in singapore
but it doesn't appear to make a big
difference to the outcome clinically
at least with respect to the genome
information there is nothing to indicate
that the viruses have changed
substantially to
have a difference in their pathogenicity
that's right so with respect to the
virus
there hasn't been any change
okay thank you all right you guys just
we're at our time and then we could
continue this conversation
um for you know many more minutes and
many more questions we do have
more q a coming through unfortunately
we're going to have to go to
the next session but what i'd like to do
is thank everyone
in our audience for engaging and
submitting questions and all of our
speakers on our panel
for their presentations and for their
dialogue and for their conversations
today we really appreciate it
and um and just really want to thank you
for your time
and so especially this concludes our
first session of our theme the science
of infectious disease
the content will be available post event
on demand through the lab roots platform
and please stay with us for our second
theme this afternoon
the economics of disease control
considerations for public health thank
you everyone
thank you thank you thank you
thank you
you